wherever there's an ocean there's going
to be some big Empire that wants to
control it but there's one ocean up at
the top of the world that hasn't ever
been controlled by great Powers because
it's literally Frozen most of the time
but that's changing because up here in
the Arctic things are heating up four
times faster than the rest of the planet
and some big countries see a lot of
money and influence hiding under the ice
Sarah deposits of fossil fuels shipping
routes and minerals so what it's turned
into is all of these countries Russia
the United States and even China who's
not even an Arctic country but kind of
wants to be an Arctic country which
isn't all of them are now vying for
influence in the Arctic Greenland
belongs to the Kingdom of Denmark they
are a member of the military alliance
called NATO the US even has a military
base up here but Greenland is also kind
of tied to China a lot of their economy
relies on sending fish to China the
result of all of this is tension more
and more every year I actually went to
Greenland to try to understand what this
really important Island means for the
future of influence in the Arctic